and now Tim Dylan is going to have
[Music]
welcome to Tim Dylan is going to hell
everybody this is Tim Dylan there will
be no video for this episode because I
am in New York City this is the final
episode from New York City we are also
changing the name of the show from Tim
Dylan's going to hell to the Tim Dylan
show we had a little contest for artists
to submit sketches of what they thought
the new show should you know what the
the I thought the [ __ ] Apple podcast
art should be and very quickly somebody
accused me of taking advantage of
artists because I said I would get the
free tickets and I would pay them to
like if we use your art I guess or what
the comedy shows which I said listen if
let's end the art in yeah by the way
fully expecting we're using none of it
and guess what we're using none of it
right and I fully expected that he's
saying hey Shen the art in because
here's the thing with the way art works
it'd be a lot of these people like look
at all the other things I've done that
doesn't matter right your portfolio
doesn't matter
I can still bomb if you go to if you
watch my special or you see me do
something you go oh that was funny I
liked him and then you come see me and I
bought I can still ruin your night but I
bumped so if I think your other your
portfolio is great it doesn't mean that
you're gonna do something that I like
well I mean that is the only way you can
go I mean know a sketch you have to
submit a sketch yeah you got to give me
an idea where you're going sure so and
then if I was gonna use the sketch right
I will compensate you monetarily okay
but if they said anything in and you
don't use it you'll still give them
tickets
no no what comic what it would no Acacio
cortez no it people are sending stick
figures in of of me going Epstein did
9/11 which I liked that one right but
there no you're not getting free tickets
for said anything if I choose your are
well here's the thing no there is no
thing but go I'm agreeing with you
because you want to start calling your
fanbase now because you
what you are calling them you know give
or take my point is you want a loyal
mercenary fanbase oh yeah you know you
want like a [ __ ] in the pest army if
you will
you want something you could get in like
you know people who will be like in for
the 10-year run you don't want people
like you know oh you're gonna get me a
ticket [ __ ] that you do it just so if I
can talk to you what the FBI didn't know
who we are right you know what I mean
what's below like what are the proud
boys are they terrorists or they
consider the terrorism I think they
knock them back down whatever below that
is you're just right below that yeah you
want to be on the board going who are
these guys we want to be on a cork board
somewhere in Jersey and having some
low-level FBI agent go let's keep tabs
on that the YouTube views are growing no
but my whole thing was listen send in
the [ __ ] if you like it okay we'll give
you some money or give you a few hundred
bucks 500 bucks whatever if we use it
right and then some lunatic guy starts
messing me goes I've been ripped off by
many podcasts the Kumi has made
thousands of dollars selling my shirts
I'm like dude not giving them shirts if
you've been ripped off by even one
podcast it's probably your fault but let
alone multiple one so I'm like dude I'm
not going to take the art this art was
for the Apple for the Apple podcast [ __ ]
for the thumbnail whatever it is it was
not just put on shirts and sell and
never compensate the artist but again of
course we have to yeah if it's a if it's
your you know your brand your little
icon I mean that's worth a few a few
bits yeah you good a few bucks
I would I would absolutely pay for that
but the shirts I'm gonna sell will have
quotes all right that's the things I
said and more so than like the you know
whatever I tried to sell copies with us
by the way I didn't introduce led to be
back right know who I am
the new people we've gotten up so a lot
of people don't know you're right should
I say hello mister I know who you guys
say hello to you know you're in your
friend who's my friend mr. Brogan you
want it you want it you think that's how
you're gonna get on the show
I don't want minutes doing a show
talking about how he's the [ __ ] so
you don't want to get on the show I'll
come on cuz you HOT you're very hostile
for a minute
[Applause]
what am I gonna fly to California wait
for my goddamned I [ __ ] on that [ __ ]
show it's ridiculous he wants to ask me
about how he's taking your skin and put
on my hands fingerprint morgue you know
I just had to put their skin on my hand
like he loved that wouldn't it be
hilarious if somehow you had the most
controversial robe like it wasn't Alex
Jones like YouTube throws him off just
get rid of millions in a drab because of
you because you're describing some crime
you committed at the morgue it wasn't
right this was this was a procedure
yeah the method I used look we were
respectful to these bodies we didn't
[ __ ] these bodies most people that
sounded like something that robert
muller would say most people don't know
this but ray who did the show for two
and a half years with me
was a photographer at a Long Island
morgue right and and and then moved into
other activities at the your job the
scope of your job was enlarged well look
I mean look that first of all that was
part of my job the taking the photos the
skin thing on the hand cuz I think
fingerprints that was my job
but yes sometimes I would clean the
bodies move the bodies on off the x-ray
table one time they let me cut open a
rib cage with a bolt cutter I suspect
this is Jeff s removes the intestines
and why would you milk the intestines
have you ever looked intestines no see
I'm not against a mob all for trying new
experiences I've never left the country
I didn't go through an airplane till was
34 right yeah I did milk an intestine a
Ghirardelli did cut open
ribcage with bolt cutters snack which
was not technically what the in the you
were not hired to do that right no look
I mean you know if you're play field Ron
James playing a basketball he's a power
forward he can't get a rebound that I
don't know if that is a fitting analogy
maybe not
I play all positions I know and I
appreciate that I would love I would
love you to go on Joe show and then
discuss your career sure at the morgue
which she's ended tragically the
mosquito lab but yeah when they moved
you the mosquito that yeah yeah
interesting when you talk about the dark
side along island right which touch for
us is you really only side I mean
there's other sides to other you know
you know the seafoods good but the rest
of it you've you've lost somebody that
worked at the morgue you just saw oh
yeah the ms-13 body machetes see in the
machetes in the bodies the drunks the
heroin OD he's hidden the [ __ ] guy [ __ ]
that with a tree branch in the ass right
you know that baby in the freezer in the
garbage bag on Christmas Eve on
Christmas Eve yeah baby in the freezer
in a garbage bag of Christmas he was
frozen solid we couldn't count me I
couldn't cut him open until Christmas
yeah overnight but I'm thaw out and you
had to cut him open on Christmas and I
didn't do that one that was a real
Johnny Cash they wouldn't let me you
know dude extra stuff you hardly had the
fall baby out overnight on Christmas
yeah really I wasn't there when I was
one of those [ __ ] you know heat lamps
but you know yeah we've left him in the
area that wasn't refrigerated and yeah
the next day I mean I was working
Christmas that year so we're gonna tell
you so I'm [ __ ] we come in and
Christmas Day we [ __ ] at the Coppola
kid so this is Chris Wow well you know
this is what me and ray initially became
friends because I found these stories
fascinating you know the comedy industry
did not know networks did not like as my
stories they did not really they like
the bagel guy they like yeah well you
know I've seen you do a lot worse than
the bagel guy but I mean I thought he
was tamed yeah I thought that bagel that
was pretty taken her name was life dude
I was I told the story last week on this
show I was
Taco Bell morbidly obese woman with
purple hair right was screaming at the
cashier going I'm a vegan
I just ate sour cream don't you think
that's a [ __ ] problem I asked it
there was no sour cream in this I just
hates our couscous I've been a vegan for
almost a year the lady can barely
understand English cashier and then it
is in a cage somewhere they get this fat
lady with the purple hair looks at me
she goes they don't care this restaurant
doesn't care and I said here's the thing
people don't realize about Long Island
point the camera any in any direction
you get bagel guy yo and more well I've
been in situations where like cuz old
women will be a bit abusive as that guy
yeah I remember I don't never what three
oh ten years ago probably I was in a
post office I think in Hicksville his
old woman was berating the [ __ ] guy
behind the counter because he didn't
have the butler package and she was just
being and she's being awful so I took it
upon myself so shut up you [ __ ] you get
cancer guys screaming so you have
situations where like you have big
people outdoing each other in public
spaces like you don't run up beat like
the big guys like should have had a
counterpart you know I mean the other
guy beat him up so I guess that counts
but usually doesn't get physical I wish
that had been a fat woman yeah like a
fat female bus driver oh just me what no
against bagel right I just went in there
and laid him out but I was I was in Long
Island today I went with channeling her
when I go to his beach club I go to the
beach clubs once a year here to uh
remember the days when I was a king well
when I was in overweight chain-smoking
pool lifeguard at a beach club in Long
Island uh eating food like people have
recognized you from weird lifeguard days
do not really know you got no because I
mean it's he's a member of a different
Beach Club okay they barely recognized
me when I shot my [ __ ] pilot the
Comedy Central probably won't pick up
right at the same Beach Club but that
was your Beach Club that was my Beach
Club that we shot the pine I didn't
recognize you a few people but the
already the more gone you know people
move the kids get older you have to put
on for you I've put on a few pounds skin
doesn't look quite the same no I mean
you know Shadley it doesn't look that
different oh you had best getting back
then no but I mean it wasn't great okay
so we're at the beach club and uh you
know people that haven't been a beach
club you pay money to get this little
Cabana it's like eight grand for the
year right and you get access to a pool
which is whatever and a private beach
and you could go in the water and
whenever one of the lifeguards jump down
I was like I'm a fan and I was like
thanks a lot man whatever and then uh so
I was really happy it was a it was a fun
day we're only there for a few hours you
know I'm gawking at some 18 year old
kids Scott's like this is embarrassing
he's like he's like you're being very
obvious oh well this is why they work
out
is it not why they work out but right so
you can't control if you want to be hot
right here's the thing folks what we
we're with your hand in your pants I was
in the pool so here's the thing folks
but you could still sort of forearms
kind of floating towards your fat gut
and it's like he seems like he might be
touching himself they know I was
adjusting my gosh getting ready here's
the thing I know this may be unpopular
in a me-too world right but if you lead
with hot if you're [ __ ] hot and this
kid was in at college whatever sure like
you can't control yes a lot of hot girls
will like you but yeah that's who's also
gonna be attracted oh yeah me no sure
sorry what why well fat woman swoon over
men like that I don't know yeah cause
like you said most gay guys whoever
similar demeanor to you yeah are as open
about you know nothing you're like a
predator predator but I could go
undercover and pretend to be straight
you could yeah I'd be like hey let's be
bros let's hang out with this sounds
menacing well well let's be friends you
know let's start an organic friendship
because you're a young man I'm an older
man and I'd know the little bit about
the world not a lot I don't have credit
but present you do
I don't have a lot to share but that's
the thing it's like this kid gave me
kind of a weird look because I was
staring at him it's like dude don't you
get that's what this is did you have
sunglasses on were you're being calm
down sir that's you you were just with
that looked like no glasses on nothing
you weren't even playing it cool you
were just gawking got a guy yeah I mean
no I'm wearing right at his kidney oh I
wasn't wait wait from the back
no he's a kidney in the back as it was
it's right here Wow well then he turned
around I was looking he's keep five
minutes staring at him oh you can wear
his thick V would be he was an
attractive gentleman it was a lifeguard
and I was looking at him and I don't do
that with women progressive yeah I'm
trying to white knight in my way into a
[ __ ] yo TV show I'm saying
well that's by the way if you white
knight your way the show I will be
nothing but impress your a business
disgusting thing arises listen this fall
Tuesdays at 10:00 I've white Diane
myself into this it is a safe space how
do you ever caught yourself looking at a
lovely lady of course but you like you
you treat it like the Sun you'll just
like stare at it for [ __ ] like
minutes on that I was getting a little I
was too much looking yeah too much
looking right and I realize that yeah I
realize that but this is the way it is
so if you're a hot guy out there you
deserve it all these hot guys take Oh
women get gorked out all the [ __ ]
time oh no you can't get cocked that
yeah maybe somebody came ahead of your
deck that's the thing baby maybe you're
bouncing the scales I am we're doing
more than any of these meet new people I
like the way you're going yeah I license
turn this may turn around it's fair game
I like this turn yeah I think I'm doing
my part because I think men need to know
what it feels like to be ogled right by
an ogre
yeah and they're not yeah because I
wouldn't be opening otherwise there's
all these obviously attracted all my
jokes that these [ __ ] young kids do
they get on stage like you know
gay guys hit on you it's cool and you're
always like you're always like like
yours like no matter what you're always
like you know I hope the guy likes me
like yeah that's all these you know they
it's this it's just breed of humor now
we're a good-looking guy we'll get up on
stage and talk about how how good gay
guys are very direct but whether or not
and it's a lot of people have this
similar temperature the guys are ready
you don't think that's true dude maybe
sexually direct that's what I mean okay
like if you're at a bar at a gay guy
wants to [ __ ] you they'll go up to you
and be like hey buddy where's a woman
it's it's more of a dance yeah so this
is kind of comedy but it always assumes
usually that the gay guy is a certain
type of gay guy or whatever you know
maybe has a little money in shape guy
what about me yellow peg leg what about
me you got some type of some bean
burrito staying on your I go up to you
know my hand boys you smell like nachos
and halitosis
what is halitosis your breath your
speciality breath oh it's like a
habitual bad breath yeah interesting I
think I I'm not saying you're not
perfumed you got that perfumed
homosexual man right well I'm not I'm
not a perfect person you don't smell
like [ __ ] nice but I think that I
think people should I think well number
what traditional masculinity is under
attack sure under attack in this country
I mean look which is why a man like
yourself or a man like myself now it's
not respected but these Zac Efron
[ __ ] are you know these pretty boys I
feel like in the 1970s Brian Dennehy was
a man that got [ __ ] wet right do you
understand what I mean Brian Dennehy a
sex symbol I believe to an extent I mean
you know Kay my conception of history he
was cuz I was around Irish women yeah
okay yeah with when he started actor
before he was 50 I don't know okay I
think that now I don't know anyway no
look I I feel like I'm actually in my
and the Golden Age from where I come
yeah cuz it's like I'm not so
Alfa Italian like hold on I'm gonna I
got I got a non-dairy haagen-dazs
chocolate I just got to put it in the
freezer keep going okay yeah I'm not one
of these guys who's like you know in
town I'm not just pretty disparaging the
Italians but they're more outgoing with
their uh you have masculinity and their
[ __ ] you know they'd be put on the
[ __ ] Brut whatever whatever telling
you guys words Cologne and they go out
to the club I'm not that kind of
masculine I'm just kind of dirty and
they wear the same shirt every day and
they have psoriasis on my leg and people
at least in Brooklyn are so now on used
to seeing anyone who isn't kind of I
don't know what you call it not you know
not traditionally mad like they kind of
seem to gravitate towards me though you
know I feel like there's a certain
credence they give me that maybe I
really you know I don't have to
demonstrate my bona fides well yeah
you're Europe you are a harkening of the
apocalypse they find you refreshing is
my point and they and as they should
yeah people that are still trying to
like I've said this many times when when
I meet somebody when they are optimistic
about the future right I think they're
mentally ill doesn't make any sense
they're mentally I'm like I don't know
what set of statistics beliefs
I mean I'm lost and that doesn't mean
that you have to be a debbie downer I'm
a happy guy you're a happy guy I'm
enjoying having fun I'm making
synthesizer music now where you're doing
electronic music yeah it's it no one
asked for that and you've put it out
right into the world right but to me
some of our cynicism is reflected in in
it in the way that we present sure I
mean look no one is like inviting us
into like the [ __ ] you know the 8 way
[ __ ] thing going on in the Hamptons
you know no we had work our way to sexy
we have to have a personality and we
gotta earn it but my just um if I take
my pants down its Terry as [ __ ] here
is no dick be I got Ryan I can [ __ ] yeah
I know how the [ __ ] right I got a decent
thing I feel like you've given this
to a judge be very honest I can [ __ ] I
got a decent day I don't got a TV you
got a dick
so I'm at so we leave the beach club we
go to a restaurant go to steak house one
of my favorite Steakhouse is probably my
favorite steak house on Long Island
Jimmy Hayes oh it's great with her once
now in Island Park we go there and
everything about Jimmy Hayes is great
it just feels racist you know like and
that's what a steakhouse should feel
like you don't [ __ ] start with me
the pictures are well if it sounds
racist only if you listen to the
conversations the pictures are on the
wall are all golfers they got great food
yeah and I'm sitting there we have a
great dinner and Scott's got two little
kids there and they're like three or
whatever they're they're holding them
together for most of the meal and then
around dessert they start to scream and
I'm like let's get out of here we can't
have dessert now Scott's of course upset
because he wants every free thing he can
get right he wants every course yeah
he's like I don't think they're that bad
I'm like spent a lot of money here - not
here kids screaming let's [ __ ] get
out of here
we'll get him an Italian ice or whatever
right so then Scott does this which is
like I there's three you know we get a
Chateaubriand for two which is like a
porterhouse place two filet never
there's three little bits of meat left
and I go the guy goes you want to take
it home I go No
Scott's like you should take it home I
go no he goes take it home you know you
know you like steak and eggs you can
make steak and eggs the next morning I
go hey [ __ ] I'm not walking around
with three things of me yeah in a bad
world pieces get little pieces I'm like
but sure in a car and he like doesn't
let it go yeah he's like I can't believe
he didn't take the steak huh and I'm
like dude and he got mad at me because I
said to him I'm like dude you have like
a weird poverty mentality where you're
like panicked that there won't be more
steak like there's gonna be more food
you don't have to you don't have to hold
on to the little morsels you have like
it's the Oregon
you know what I mean yeah I mean I don't
know over the poverty because I know the
guy yeah I like the guy I like him too
grifter thing going well that's part of
it as Atticus but like to me my whole
thing is like I was never a fan of it to
go go it looks trashing it looks not
ELISA treats never good hears it then
you're bringing it home to your leg if
you got kids were like 13 yeah nice
thing well my friends would bring
something home it was nice I still think
it looked like trash bag yeah earlier in
the evening yeah yeah and you know it
would be nice how about cooking those
kids dinner and instead of bringing them
home some but like to me the doggie bag
concept it says exactly what it is
you're a dog
no you're a dog this is important to us
yes it was a big night yes I don't want
any of this have you ever seen in a
restaurant
someone take like literally a table
spoon full of mac and cheese yeah and
put it like the coffee cup with a little
lid over it it makes me I want to go in
shame I remember the first one the first
time you took me to roll in skis yeah
and I it was a mate it was you know it
was a great meal yeah and I remember
when I looked around go you know what's
weird is that for a lot of these people
this is just like the diner right and
like there's nothing more they eat like
every other day right and that's where
we we should be we what we used hired to
well not being like this is a lot we
saved up we scraped napkin yeah we say a
whole year we put away pennies
we took a jar of change down we took we
turned it a bunch of cans and we end
this guy's got money he's in a house
where a brand-new car enough I'm not
[ __ ] on poor people I've been in
shitty spots where I ate I ate a wooden
bowl of baked beans and sauerkraut oh
sure when I was living in Manhattan in
that [ __ ] tenement and [ __ ] well I
will probably again mean when you were
pretending to be a victim of Sandy yes I
was it I was a vegan
the wounds were psychological I got
1,100 FEMA nice and all I lost was a Gin
Blossoms CD and I used to [ __ ] do
lines off of but you remember that when
I tried to I tried to claim the V victim
is handy oh yeah if you're watching
Breaking Bad the whole array I was
living in a five-story walk-up I was
living with
crazy comedians five-story walk-up I'm
on the fifth floor
I got a door I got no door I got a
curtain leads into my room we had
bedbugs like twice three times in a year
there was a rat in the lobby the shower
was in the kitchen of the building but I
loved it cuz I was like I was 25 I was
like doing stand-up I'm like this is my
dream I love it I mean on the roof
smoking cigarettes it was all cool and
then Sandy happened and like you know
everybody I know all my friends in Long
Island her like huddled in their
driveway with guns people trying to rob
their houses I had no power for a week
you had no power for a week everybody's
[ __ ] I'm watching Breaking Bad kind of
mad that the frozen yogurt place didn't
switch the flavors I was like oh we're
not gonna we're not gotta rotate there's
nothing new but my part in New York City
Hell's Kitchen 45th between 8th and 9th
Avenue did not lose any [ __ ] power
but then I found out that FEMA was
giving out a little cash FEMA was given
a cash so why it's smart that you never
you know you don't you're officially
change residences correct but I tried to
sing the song and they're like listen we
usually give people 35 Hans we're gonna
give you 11 hunter they smelled a little
fraud right on me but they were kind of
it was kind of like Christmas on Long
Island it was like everyone was like you
know there was a I worked oh yeah I bet
I profited off because I remember I was
at the morgue and the county was trying
to do a scam with FEMA
this is fascinating I don't know I have
to say allegedly I guess because this is
a speculation we did but basically they
set up these different locations mostly
in schools or in town halls these FEMA I
don't like what you call them it these
centers like these these try emergency
centers it would basically just
information you have a good you know
official insurance guys from the state
who come help you out tell you have a
[ __ ] file your claims and [ __ ] now I
the morgue report the health department
and they want like they're basically
everyone was allowed to go and work this
thing and Health Department had like
their Flyers with like you know don't
get [ __ ] black mold or whatever and
there was no cap and we were making like
a huge overtime so I would go after work
and get like eight hours of [ __ ] like
go there for eight hours just basically
out of hand that far as if people came
but no one really came by much anything
did why were they doing it cuz the
[ __ ] County we believe was trying to
like profit cuz the state was gonna
reimburse them but for more money
it's not this Long Island they're trying
to like do CH like what pay us for like
charity whatever we're volunteer work so
they can get reimbursed for more from
the state and it backfired and it wants
all that money what people don't
understand is if America is is is
largely not all but largely a group of
incredibly selfish dishonest people
right let's just say that's a lot of us
okay and you know one thing if that's
the case Long Island is a concentration
of that right in a way that's hard to
believe
unless you've spent any significant
amount of time there when Sandy happened
people automatically thought about how
it could be used for their benefit okay
now some people were genuinely hurt and
their lives were destroyed right but
then there were many people a lot of
people yeah who use that for the next
seven years as an excuse look these
people you your monoi pointing this now
yeah people live their lives waiting for
their parents to die your grown people
they have their own house but their
retirement plan is their dead mother
right and they have their own house
because they took equity out of their
mother's house down payment exactly yeah
no all right so it does something to
that that then forms the way you live
it's an entitlement that's become so
deeply ingrained in them it's cultural
right well I take cultural entitlement
in Long Island where people feel
entitled to a house right that doesn't
exist and you go anywhere
these [ __ ] feel entitled to a house
and by the way these aren't like the
like this isn't like the Kennedys where
it's like a level of privileged backed
with education and to a degree service
or even let's say let's be cynical and
say the service is only to dominate
others it's still part of the plan yeah
this is I feel entitled to a house
simple
because I will [ __ ] out in Mercy
Hospital or NASA County Medical Center
or lij I add like I have no education I
have no marketable skills I'm a medical
biller I'm I work at a you know I wear
doctors outfit but I'm not a doctor I'm
a [ __ ] receptionist at a massage
parlor
I worked retail jobs where like the
sister the manager but you know I got me
50 grand a year prior yeah but like
taking [ __ ] from the boss and the boss a
millionaire
I think it's chipping the balls all the
time ago ah [ __ ] him my dad dies in like
2030 years I'm gonna have a million
dollars and like he meant it what is
like is like this is how these people
cope with doing nothing people openly
discuss this yeah this isn't a hidden
thing that they're waiting for their
parents to die right this is it like
swept under the rug it's right out in
front
yeah it's a big thing when I do jokes
about it people laugh yeah they get it
because you know people are some people
are more open with it than others right
but it's not it's not him um and I would
just you know sit there with Scott I
picked up the tab was expensive I no
problem with it we had everything and
then it just he said we've gotten an
argument on the way home so I'm like
dude it's this mentality this grimy
you're clinging it like they'll be more
food right it's gonna be okay you're not
in a situation where you need every no
one is on Long Island nobody walking out
with leftover some Texas Roadhouse needs
them these are not the people that
aren't that a fight there's gonna be
more mac and cheese next week don't
worry folks you know but I'm leaving New
York I thought I was gonna hold on to my
apartment I'm not holding on to my
apartment describe what you're looking
at you've been here by yeah I've been
here before
it looks like you're uh basically just
like 25th hour you and you're going
you're going to the penitentiary
tomorrow and you're just kind of
settling your affairs and like actually
looks like the place where Brooks hung
himself in Shawshank does that kind of
place it's like I don't know the
radiators from the is from the before
the depression the doors are like school
door
you know weird school doors that have
like glass in their wood and glass but
it's a type of glass we can't really see
in know yeah they look like you're
broken down when he's like a Japanese
family lived here during the War World
War two and I moved to LA already but I
thought I was just gonna keep this
apartment cause I was gonna come back to
New York a lot and then I just made the
decision I'm kind of done yeah you look
you like you you you value uh maybe to a
fault even yeah a lack of hassle right
this place is kind of like a-- but it's
for many reasons a depressing place
don't obey your head what happens to me
is a lack of hassle becomes hassle right
that's a lot look that is part of the
game okay like how many friendships do I
have that you've rightly pointed out
right I get something out of it yeah but
the insanity that comes with it right is
so far outweighs and then I realize that
this epiphany I'm like oh I'm not even
like a smart player I just I'm addicted
to insanity
well here's the thing are you just kind
of like crazy yeah because you like the
people you I don't think you say his
name on the air but like you know that
your friend from the mortgage place
whatever Howie Howie yeah well you do
like you look up to the you're not
booked up right you value these people
but these like you actually have you're
intelligent you have talent you're
succeeding at something else these
people who keep all these balls in the
air it's because they're living in like
the day-to-day hustle and that's all
they have right and that's like that's
like there's a certain thing to admire
there but like why do I like them
because you have a romantic view of like
you know like the cantine street urchins
and Vitus you know and like you know the
confederacy of dunces and you view like
you view you like low-level hustlers
right but you know you also weren't
hanging around st. Mark's getting
stamped all the time by them uh I feel
like yeah you grew up you want the old
New York and you and you like where they
represent because the alternative is
disgusting also crack it me really is
gross if nothing else they help clean
out some of the uh you know these
gentrifying idiot me I'm terrified too I
guess for the except we will ever point
is you're not chant refine your DJ at
your fine
you the prices go down I think if I
shouldn't feel bad you did not feel out
but I'm counteracting absolutely like
myself no but that's the problem you and
you're not they're not these like you
know these guys aren't written by
Gilbert and some of them there's
something about this is they're actually
like stupid low-level people are boring
the hustle is actually kind of boring
well you're what I've started to realize
that I was so good a friend of mine
recently I won't say their name and I
was talking to her and I realized I was
going you know what for for all the
madness that these people bring into my
life that a lot of is very funny
a lot of is very it's never boring it's
very funny but here's the thing you just
kind of hit the nail on the head it does
start to get boring but it actually does
start to because you realize these
people never evolved on in any way and
oh they're a lot of them are just deeply
selfish people right who are afraid to
grow and evolve so what they do is they
have these crazy lives and they have the
and they populate their lives with crazy
characters but at the end of the day
it's just a [ __ ] excuse to never
account for their own behavior that's
what it is yeah that's really what it is
all right yeah no it's like I mean you
see these are the same people you
probably hung out with who are you know
whose kids were you know on Easter
Sunday [ __ ] you know it's a joke I
have in my Akron or I'd go to a bar and
Easter Sunday and you know I don't want
to get my joke away but whatever it's
all over so it is you know well you know
the moms in the bar getting drunk right
point is like it all seems fun in a joke
right like when you actually know that
person it's just sad and also like get
you never it's like when you gonna get
your act together because that's the
feeling of like how many times do you
tell someone there's something I liked
about the freedom now I will be on I
still like about people that resist
convention and there was something about
a lot of the people that I knew in that
period and a lot of them were drunks and
a lot of them were not but they're you
know you you look at some of the people
that I'm around now in the entertainment
business and like the cognitive
dissonance some of them
okay like they're the good guys you know
right they're really they're the
revolute they're the resistance and you
know and then you look at their lives
and you go oh you're you're you're
you're doing the exact same things as
all the people that you hate really I
mean literally the stories there's no
one to look up to there's right Robert
ruler
yeah actually I'm service I mean every
senator I love you watching his [ __ ]
hearing now what was that like every
caught me it was just it's not what he
said he was good he was good I mean I
can't into that I want to elaborate read
the report yeah how'd you bring me here
right but also everyone every [ __ ]
congressman was like thank you for
serving in Vietnam what you know he's
just [ __ ] like you he torched some
village and like [ __ ] yes Dave aren't
these the people that were rightly
against Vietnam aren't these the people
that didn't want Vietnam he actually I
was reading mr. Muller you know 20 years
of the black thank you for your service
at Guantanamo Bay now tell us about he
was I was reading saying he was in the
Marine Corps in Vietnam there for a year
told his wife I'm thinking about staying
to hold this forever and she's like what
and then they transferred him to like a
desk job and he like quickly his quote
was I didn't relish the Marine Corps
absent combat this guy just liked
killing [ __ ] peasants god I didn't I
didn't relish the Marine Corps absent my
boot on somebody's neck nice folks we
have talked endlessly about the
importance of having a website on this
show I think I've moved many of you to
understand why you need to have a
website even in a world that is rapidly
collapsing you know in no time we will
probably have massive civil unrest we
will have certainly climate emergencies
probably more disasters climate change
things like that we'll probably have a
crisis in the legitimacy of the
government and ruling institutions I
can't
see how we won't
perhaps a separation of the military and
the political structure I don't again
I'm just looking at some of the signs I
mean this could potentially not happen
as well I don't know you might see a
total takeover of all available
platforms by a technocracy where
everything you say becomes some type of
advertisement for something and we're
all just selling each other things I
don't know maybe that's preferable I
don't know and I don't care all I want
for all of you is to have a place to put
your content so that people can see it
go to Tim Dylan's going to hell comm TI
m di ll ons going to hell calm there is
no is just the s Dylan's going to hell
it was a site built using Wix Wix is
really amazing so many stunning
templates they are stunning automated
drag-and-drop website builder very easy
to use even if you're not that bright
and I assume many of you or not they
have an artificial design intelligence
Wix Adi
that's what andrew yang is talking about
so you don't have to do anything you can
just answer a few simple questions and
Wix is going to design your website for
you so even in this time of potential
chaos of devolution we must think about
being on brand it's very important that
we stay on brand through the apocalypse
how to do that have a web site where you
can embed video text links telling you
nobody will be helped in an end time
scenario by people that do not
have a well-defined brand you get it
people want hard lines around you they
want to know that you are a fully
fleshed out thing they could look and
listen and go we get it that's essential
even in a time when small groups of
people are fighting over resources you
should be a well defined brand people
need to know what they what they're
getting okay so do me a favor
go to Tim Dylan's going to hell dot-com
Wix will give you 10% off any premium
plan over 150 million people have built
their website using Wix Tim Dylan's
going to hell calm Wix will give you 10%
off any premium plan I mean you know
what did you say about the 911 thing
that was fun bring Nana well he look he
took the job of FBI director the week
before 9/11 and he retired a few months
after the Boston bombing
it's crazy nicely bookend and yeah I
don't know if the FBI really dimming
that wrong in the ensuing years I mean
you know when were they involved in
renditions in secret or I mean I think I
would all word say my default is forced
and of course they were right I mean
like that's the thing look he seems to
have done a relatively professional job
but you're losing sight of the fact
you've brain the FBI pretend yeah he's
one of the most corrupt organizations
I've ever seen well what we're living in
upside-down topsy-turvy world where we
have Bush torture era apologists on
MSNBC and we have you know Ann Coulter
on you know like siding with Infowars
now it's like it's really it nothing
means anything right nobody has any
values nobody cares
right about we you know what their
entire worldview was six months ago you
know it's a constantly churning and the
thing with the Muller investigation to
me is
it we're no longer watching the movie
like for lack of a better way to like
explain things right that movie's over
yeah and we're not watching anymore
sure Twitter's watching it right uh uh
uh you know the blue checkmarks that
they're still heavily invested in it the
idea that you could maybe get trump on
obstruction when the Seoul Central case
that you cannot prove that him or his
team conspired directly with them it's
not proven well I think here's the thing
and this is usually contentious he
wouldn't answer it and he's true I think
he's preserved from preserve the
evidence for after Trump leaves office
when they can actually charge them
because he's very much seems to be of
the opinion will not leave my keys gonna
die in office and then Ivanka will take
over and we're talking maybe twenty
thirty that sounds fun but he's like
he's buggin because he's he's I think he
there's that whole Justice Department
think well you can't charge of sitting
President Andrew Dice isn't pregnant and
so he's kind of sticking to that so I
don't think he's saying that you
couldn't get him on obstruction I think
he's just saying I'm not allowed to get
my obstruction but after we Lou but he's
not trying to try not to [ __ ] yet I
guess this is a big deal if you weren't
really but you lost here's the thing I
believe he did a lot of stuff wrong yeah
I believe I don't know if he concluded
clue you on purpose but the way if you
didn't think Trump was a criminal I
guess this is good for you right the way
he acted that's the fact I mean clearly
on the surface if it's not some
obstruction of justice
it might as well but it's like it's not
becoming of anything deliver public that
being said politically speaking you lost
and now you just know these Democrats
have no sense of how they're appearing
to the other side it'll bug to me well
like it's also the idea that like there
are there are issues to run on yeah
there are issues to run on you have a
guy that has not really fulfilled any of
his campaign promises you have a broken
health care system do you think that the
kemal Harry should say I'm gonna really
[ __ ] build this wall well I'm gonna
[ __ ] build an even bigger I think if
Democrats continue to run on that open
borders and that there is that they're
gonna provide health care for anybody
who comes to the country illegally right
and that every
every did all that any kind of migration
is Asylum seeking which is just is not
the case and if the standard for solemn
seeking is that you're coming from a
violent place
that's everywhere in the world that's so
many places sure that's literally
billions a to be fair yeah uh we like
these places are kind of [ __ ] up and I
love that every case necessarily but
like he's because of uh you know I a
hundred percent over their [ __ ] you
know listen now I am with you a hundred
percent right and if somebody would like
to tell me how to unwind the
military-industrial complex right I will
I mean within reason sure I would listen
Tulsi has some good ideas I think maybe
I'll support Bernie because he's the
only one that's not on a conga line with
Jeffrey Epstein
that's nice or the restaurant supporting
him no I mean Trump Clinton they've
already a party is something nice about
one guy that's not do you think it's
kind of like when the drug kingpin goes
away his turf is up for grabs
like when with Epstein like the other
elite pedophiles are like vying for his
kids
well well these kids are adults now well
he's been [ __ ] he was [ __ ] under
this eerie bow that's true these people
in the doctor says kids have one-woman
shows that a big we positively mean dude
I've seen kids
I don't know how AB C goes down I do
think that it has a potential to be a
big scandal I do think you're gonna see
a lot of boldface names and I do think
what will happen unfortunately is you're
gonna see so many boldface names people
are gonna it's gonna have the opposite
effect where people are gonna be like
they all can't be doing this right and
yes they can but I think that is gonna
make people go you know I'm sure some of
them were some of them weren't like
there's this great thing that the media
is doing already where they're focusing
on Trump and Clinton right reps team
Trump and Clinton which we were wrong
two years ago everybody was on the mall
and and come to everybody else and why
doing that people are at home being like
well it's a wash job clay and it's like
no it not only is it not a what it is
nothing to do like Bill Maher
would talk about that years ago
something else he goes like the
Republicans are really good at like it's
a wash right where it's like you know
they do the Swift Boat Veterans in them
like it's a wash yeah whatever it's like
no it's not a watch once I didn't show
up for the surface one guy went served
Facebook yeah yeah it's evil but the
greatest move every it's one of the
greatest political stunts for the Swift
Boat Veterans why don't you respect this
country why don't you why aren't you
hopeful for the future of this country I
mean guys the swift lift the good name
the Swift Boat Veterans for explain this
briefly right all right so basically
John Kerry is like this is the what the
old for election yeah
after the Iraq war started you guys both
and scallop bounds yeah george w bush
toured the Iraq war everyone's man
that's right and Carrie's gonna run and
the Democrats are all afraid cuz you
know no one's got a war record and
you're all gonna say you're soft on
defense because 9/11 still thing right
so Kerry's like hey [ __ ] you I was in
Vietnam there was this whole thing I
served in Vietnam I was a commander over
Swift or whatever and you know and like
I I [ __ ] served my country
and so you can't you change her and Punk
me out so they had a problem right but
karl rove is a you know a wily guy so he
[ __ ] gets these guys he started
organization what gets these guys to
start your organization called Swift
Boat Veterans for truth and now I think
in actuality knows him served with Kerry
none of them knew Kerry I'm not sure if
they were in the military but their
story was that they served with Kerry
and his story he had a story about like
saving someone over Swift Boat yeah and
like jumping on a grenade
one of them's on Infowars all the time I
forget and they just [ __ ] and they
just hammered him they [ __ ] went out
there none of it was true a [ __ ] guy
we saw him he ran away he actually threw
a grenade at the scible troops he was
there working for Charlie he was there
work yeah
so they torn apart of the guy and he
loses the election which I fell for that
like I was in that mindset of like
falling for that when I was
younger because liberals are so annoying
is people right that day they turn you
off on a level where even if they're
right right you're reluctant what sort
of thing of like george w bush is a
[ __ ] like he wasn't the right guy right
objectively but like it's just never
it's never does never any nuance to it
is ready no i really think this guy is a
complete imbecile now and the idea is
that the people that were saying that
were never people that that i looked at
it like it was always like oh forgot a
deli so i'm got his [ __ ] me a
sandwich
they liked bush but it was always with
some other it's a public school teacher
where it's like oh great okay thank you
what do you do hand out folders um but
it's a time now where you know when you
look at the FC news and we've had a lot
of first of all i think it's kind of
hilarious and let's even though I like
these guys I loved it like you know
we've had rust paper on the show we had
Nick Bryan on the show I don't like
Brian's name in the news well now yeah
he's break this story but this is my
point okay this is my point okay these
two guys that we've had on this [ __ ]
show act like nothing can ever get to
the level of winner and then this Julie
K Brown at the Miami Herald breaks this
thing wide open
where are these two right where are they
you know now Nick Bryant was on the
story a long time ago that's great right
and he probably got described now there
is this moment in the media bakery he
had that seems black book yeah and he
leaked it to Gawker okay this is before
or after this whole thing before years
ago okay Baker talk about this ones
because there's a moment in every story
when it's okay and then all the media
like the dam breaks and the media's
allowed to go after it now we're in that
moment you know I think it's just kind
of hilarious now they're like all these
your business insiders like is to what
is this temple on his island and is this
door meant to keep people in it it's not
it's just painted that way but like I
love like it's hilarity linton being
like I was never on the pedophile it
reminds me of the whole thing with the
we started getting into this whole child
yeah beginning to you researching it
yeah and like they put the [ __ ] the
goat head on right it's like your
[ __ ] kids isn't that enough right
these people like and like but people
get like wrapped up in the inner
Satanism of it no he's [ __ ] kids
right matter if there's a temple on this
[ __ ] oh she [ __ ] is he chanting while
he's suffering is [ __ ] [ __ ] with
eight-year-olds ass I think what it is
is there's a an element of it that when
you start to include that other stuff
for whatever reason is so like it's so
it's such a paradigm shift right that it
starts to break down any well they could
cope with a Hasker for instance like
this Hasker with speaker to have a
majority leader or think Speaker of the
House and he has two convicted pedophile
and he might be still in jail I'm not
sure yeah I mean no one did not but like
but the idea that there's like an
underground uh like you know Society or
like a secret you know skullenbones of
pedophiles well it captivates the idea
that you know and this has been said I
forget whose quote this was that you
know the ruling classes yet it's like
they're into things that are were you
know worse than if they I think somebody
reviewing Nick Brian's book said if this
stuff is true
well it's that certain members of the
ruling class were in this stuff that's
worse than you know Caligula's dream
like well really depraved stuff and I
think you know when you get into that
stuff whether it's MKULTRA whether it's
mind control whether it's ritual a beaut
what when you start to read about that
stuff it's so [ __ ] it's like opening a
door into literal hell right and then
you go oh none of this can be true and
then you start realizing oh no a lot
like oh yeah enough of it is true at
least thing I like boats I like nice
shrimp yeah but that being said you look
at how hard to me some of them inherit
the money but like rich people was like
your ass off and then do like devote
their lives this collection of resources
it can't all be for shrimp right you
know right that there's a reason some of
these people are [ __ ] making these
yeah one of my favorite things you've
ever said was do you think we're not
successful because we're not pedophiles
that was that was that was maybe the one
of the
things you've ever said on the show you
were like you were like maybe this is
why things aren't working out for its
guy look I was I wouldn't trade places
with the pedophile yeah but I give you a
drive sure
do you think they go down here does
Clinton go dad
no no I think I think Epstein you know
they're pinning this on a low level
senator you know somebody some
congressmen and it's gonna be like from
a state that some irrelevant guy who
felt up somebody probably didn't even
come is going down right somebody the
guy holding the camera yeah the guy he
didn't even make it to the island right
he prematurely ejaculated on a bond on
the boat or on a raft Oliver he's really
good a 17 year old lady doing without
he's like the [ __ ] yachts yeah yeah I
mean here's the thing I think if it is
if it is Trump and [ __ ] uh Clinton
[ __ ] children on an island yeah then
that's really what happened we're like
he's like okay sorry it says possible
Clinton was just [ __ ] [ __ ] on the
island or never I mean no all right fair
enough
but my point is I'm saying if it was
here's piers great point yeah Clinton
could [ __ ] [ __ ] anywhere like there is
this fair now there is this idea listen
no fair enough right my point is if
that's what's going on
you only Epstein knows he's gonna get
[ __ ] whacked yeah I've been he can't
get this I have seen in a very secured
jail that I actually we went and stood
outside of it because we're gonna film a
scene outside of it when I was dressed
up like that girl and I was grinding on
his front door um all right then then
what three has spent the rest of his
life in the [ __ ] in the hole because he
can't go anywhere Hey ladies n't want
that so he's gonna [ __ ] play ball or a
certain extent he's not gonna flip on
that kind of [ __ ] right like what so he
can get off and then what well like
what's what's gonna I mean I would be
what just Lane Maxwell who's his partner
mmm I know I don't know what she knows
probably a lot right she was kind of
recruiting these girls just Lane Bryant
yeah she I don't think no it's not Lane
Bryant
was a fat woman go no don't
cyrodiil no that's less waxed er okay
I've seen all his money and and and and
and AB C's hedge funds probably just Lex
Westers money and a slush fund and
whatever I said was probably washing
dark money and then you were like yeah
but they have that kind of money they
don't really need human trafficking
money and I'm like yeah but why leave it
on the table they're gonna say no it's
big money you know sure um I think and
it's so funny like Acosta literally has
been quoted as saying I was told Epstein
belonged to intelligence not to worry
about not to push to prot you know who
the console again he was the Secretary
of Labor he's the one that cut Epstein
that sweetheart but it's so funny how he
goes yeah I belong to a child and it's
like when will you people kind of wake
up here when what what would do it so
when your defense is like I thought he
was [ __ ] these kids were letting
people [ __ ] these kids so we could find
out secrets about Cuba we I thought he
belong to Intel it's like well then what
well then why isn't that a problem
what's the deal I mean look the CIA is
definitely yeah we we for business
countless hours yeah I mean look I mean
he probably what look you you think you
think that he would been caught decades
ago if it wasn't for like if do you
think that people are protecting him
listen I flip information the technology
is the internet things like that have
made it had made it more difficult I
think
victims are now able to find each other
where I were able to corroborate you
know they're people are the people are
empowered now in ways that they would
not have been years ago right but if he
has that right look we don't CIA you
need to tell just agencies could be
don't hang people out to try to hang
their people of course they won't but
hit my point we know they engage in
their own sexual blackmail yeah so if
they got this guy who is running a
network to like some of the most
powerful people in the world yeah
they're gonna tap into my go hey we want
peace we want some and you gotta keep me
in the game of course so you know and
what's interesting is that you know the
FBI know are good people in some of
these organizations and I mean good in a
relative sense good like they're against
[ __ ] kids they're not really against
you know throwing people in jail for no
reason right you know I mean so it's
good
let's use good or not you know let's let
the Anglin doesn't support pedophiles
but right it's like but pyramids I love
the eye angle that that Abu Ghraib
soldiers come out to condemn Epstein for
the country we were doing it for the
country I mean look it didn't seymour
hersh have a [ __ ] he was saying that
they were [ __ ] kids seymour hersh
they said that they have a videotape of
children being sodomized or raped by i
don't know defense contract members of
the military somebody and then it's and
the same yeah and abu ghraib and their
screams and shrieks and the the military
was paranoid these these tapes were
gonna get out in those tapes where i
guess to get the parents of the kids or
something to talk I mean have you just
what happened to like drugs I mean what
ok the sixties they had what was that
this is when my quality at a lunch and
somebody's like well you know America is
probably gonna fall apart I'm like yeah
you know you know I listen I don't what
I'm not tryna I'm not saying it I don't
want any harm to come to you or your
family but like man have if any of this
[ __ ] is true we have the seeds of our
destruction
do you think it is them just being evil
and trying and like wars it's a
pedophile going again talk [ __ ] this kid
and like you know I mean like was that
gonna work yeah trust me yeah like they
just hire some pedophile he's like
listen you [ __ ] people are amateurs
here's what has to be done there's no
other way that anyone's gonna talk yeah
I think whole thing would like the
[ __ ] with the monarch program really
really big [ __ ] Kaizen so like this is
so see anything yeah it's like how many
times you have a [ __ ] kid before
becomes an assassin yeah what horrible
[ __ ] to laugh at folks but we're you
know we're living in hell I've said that
before I don't know what you want I mean
I'm glad I'm out of New York I'm glad
I'm leaving New York what what are your
feelings on New York as it is right now
I'm ready I'm ready to go um look if you
got money which I don't yeah it's it's
nice I mean I would like to go someplace
where I can [ __ ] the swing an axe
yeah we'd go fishing yeah shoot some
true shotgun in the air for no reason
yeah yo Montana maybe or when let me ask
you yeah is that arre when do you think
you can make that a reality
um Montana I think is being co-opted by
the rich so I guess that's not gonna be
great but buying a lot of land in
Montana well we might look if I was
willing to like live in a humid place on
Louisiana are you know when are you
gonna be done with the Brooklyn thing I
mean I work in like media stuff so I
mean if it's not Brooklyn maybe it's
Laurie sobbing I mean I am starting to
get into more like you know color work
which is like you know lucrative so yeah
maybe I can kind of change my quality of
life in a couple years like you're tied
down I'm tied down into like a major
city I go that way
I got a Leawood maybe I should write
with know my roommates coming and
congratulate them semi-finals Oh Allan
congratulations I heard the good news
it's this it's the quarter-finals
semi-finals you better congratulations
and if you win what do you get a
thousand bucks
it's all happening thousand dollars
that's this is this is this is New York
as a New York is your dream fast rake
open the champagne by the night look
there's nothing here I don't know why
this restaurants like what
here's think you go and you live in like
a [ __ ] in place with a lake you can
go in a kayak and if you look along Long
Island right you can okay yakking fish
in I mean there's nice things there yeah
it's like yeah we're gonna forward that
so they have that in like Michigan maybe
see a magical live in Michigan like what
kind of job I should become a trucker
maybe I mean that's job is gonna go
everyone says that's gonna get any gangs
all about yeah they're all they're all
saying but if maybe they showed a photo
of you as one of the truckers who was
losing their job right America would go
good you mr. robot they would be like
you know put AI in that vehicle right
and this guy should get no universal
basic income
running over with the truck what kind of
money do you need to live in this city
where it's not like annoying that's
nothing that what I have several hundred
thousand four hundred even if you have
150 you have a nicer place now you need
listen you need real money and you you
got listen really the New York Life not
to sound like a rich [ __ ] yeah it is
that finance guy life of hey you have
your beach house on Long Island you have
your nice apartment in Tribeca or
wherever you know you [ __ ] what you want
as long as they want it to consent
matters your you eat the best [ __ ] your
you used to have that [ __ ] st. marks
a [ __ ] Lower East Side none of it
it's not of it and that but that is
because the [ __ ] city was going
bankrupt and sorry about the tripping
and so orders you can come live here and
that's you know once that ended you know
there's just I mean comedy now it's
embarrassing it's exhausting when you're
obedient it'll do it and behind people
who've no I'm a comedian there let's go
great why do you think this book if they
saw me and think oh you were from the
guy fair enough
right but - oh you mean that's great
it's like every third [ __ ] person you
mean Brooklyn is a goddamn comedian yeah
you're all terrible yeah you're all I
know these kids are these are all
[ __ ] theater kids yes yes grown up
and it's just know none of them were
[ __ ] even a funny person in their friend
group no they're all theater kids
there's a real theater kid energy which
is very supportive a comedian tries to
be kind of cutthroat you had to get good
yeah it's a different kind of energy you
know when I started people wouldn't talk
to you if you bomb that mics it was kind
of you know brutal right theater kid
energy is like we all love each other
and we're the best and and by the way
that's not real theater energy theater
kidding no real theater is exactly what
comedy was cutthroat ileana be good yeah
tough you whatever well but theater kid
energy like high school theater program
in your [ __ ] suburbs is what we have
now it is an ultra supportive circle
jerk and the industry is just feeding
into it
well I look people go through PC it's
not that it's not even that it's not
even that just a big nothing
it's a glorification of just losers yeah
a lot of people you meet in the industry
you're like you were you
you walked her out of high school with
no confidence and you shouldn't have any
now that's the problem I mean even the
people have some sort of like I was
holding with Dina over the weekend yeah
Dina she's great I support her in the
idea of trailing a comic is insane right
but these people like this guy I'm all
cool people going after this guy who's
like it's comic right who [ __ ] went
you know yeah whatever but this guy look
host a game show on Netflix right but
this is what does it become
yes he knows right he's all posts like
you know collapse none of it yet none of
it matters right where we're walking
around in the ruins you know and trying
to find meaning and it's just like I
look at it now like I love making people
laugh I love doing this on whatever
level I can do it for whoever wants to
come out and see it but the culture is
disgust it's terrible I mean like this
there yeah on an individual level
there's some good people I've met I
don't keep up with you many of them but
like as a whole like the idea of when we
go with like so some party in a bar for
some comedians birthday and so it's just
I guess it feels gross you know you know
I performed at a comedy club I won't say
which one one of our major fans very big
fan she gave me a tour of the city I was
in and she brought you up she's one of
your patreon subscribers she's oh man of
you
she thinks Lucy's very smart and and as
soon as any was that plugged into our
lives I'm like nervous I'm like what's
happened right but she took me to lunch
she drove me around it and you know it
was very funny she goes you know I'd
never been to that Club and the club by
the way I might McGee any specific
comment about the club because his club
is literally every club for the most
part other than like five of them she
just looked at me after which she goes
it's kind of sad in there it's kind of
sad yeah and and it's like it these
Midwest clubs and Northeast it's not the
region but a lot of comedy clubs there
they look like they're from the 80s a
guy will get up who's featuring for you
and like are a cheap blazer and he'll do
like 80s jokes then he'll sit down a
complainer but like these fun
can YouTube guys to take it everything
from me and it's like sir sir sir
you know you're the host will be some
you know chubby chick who's like I'm
thinking of moving to New York I'm like
oh good how old do you she's like 38
it's like wow it's it's a broken world
I mean honestly there's a lot of
talented people out there wait wait more
talented now I'm not being a hater or
anything but it's just like there's a
handful of people who I think are
actually even do anything this like even
kind of like you know relevant or kind
of like like matters like like it makes
any kind of like shaking the webs off of
any like yeah
Carlin Pryor wow the exceptional guys
but mean yeah sort of like guys like you
know your grade in [ __ ] what's his
name Doug Stanhope my bigger problem I
place yeah everyone's just kind of I
don't know it's the problem is
everything so viscerally they're in
front of you in this society now like
everything it's all [ __ ] like you
know chaos all the time that's like I
think the whole thing is we're in this
era and we don't really know we haven't
made that jump yeah cuz the gatekeepers
still have a little bit of relevance
yeah even though that's diminishing
every day right by the way I don't I'm
not I'm not optimistic per se in a world
without the gatekeepers like everyone
right I'll go out to dinner and
somebody's like well now that people can
decide I'm like oh god helpless yeah god
help us the people people get people
people act like commuters go on forever
indefinitely and it's like jazz was big
in the 40s right right and then like
it's a client in the 60s you could see
more jazz that you can now the seventies
EA but event like now you have a couple
places you can see good jazz like it
right around right I'll have comedy but
the idea that like basically like so
that we had the boom in the 80s right
yeah it's a trajectory it goes up and
down but the general work is gonna be
like what's also listen I hate to say it
it doesn't necessarily make me happy but
the future is really gonna predominantly
be digital yeah the future is gonna be
watching things that excite you about
people and then maybe going out to see
them live but the whole idea of
comedians getting festivals and late
nights right that doesn't mean like that
paradigm of it yeah it's funny people
yeah that is yeah that is done Trump
gets out there says whatever the [ __ ] he
wants he's the president
the idea that very stilted scripted in
some cases predictable formulaic jokes
are gonna are gonna be the thing right
no that's why podcasts are people are
into it that's what people are into like
I just but to me it's like there's a
real desperation and clinginess and it's
always unattractive to be somebody who's
clinging to the past especially when
that pass is like a sad Midwest comedy
club where you get up there with a suit
jacket and tell garbage jokes it's like
you're not doing anything I think part
of the problem is that kind of all art
conformed to this I think Kanye's kind
of thing when people there's podcast and
stuff people listen to it and like some
people just enjoy and then we've always
offered that way yeah enjoy something
like that that's the perfect way to be
but like so many people go I want to do
this now and it's just so fulfilling
cycle of like it's just everyone this
whole society everyone wants it to be
them yeah they want to be the person
yeah and like no one and so everyone's
just doing is kind of like you know okay
but some people are born for this some
people are born to be [ __ ] great this
and like but a lot of people just aren't
there just waylaying like you know some
better development there and I mean
listen I'll tell you this if you want to
be in comedy stay away from people that
support you without a reason right if
you are and this is probably goes for
anything but if you're getting a lot of
support for no damn reason yeah you need
to look at who those people are and and
you know what's the thing you said yeah
unfunny people stick together like them
are kind of funny people stick together
like the Mafia used to you know the
Mafia no longer does those guys rat to
get out of jail they all go they go on
YouTube they start doing podcast I've
been watching on YouTube and that comedy
so I'm watching a lot of a prison talk
yeah these guys fresh out of prisons big
hurt yeah and there's one video about
how he has fat rat on who's a guy and
Mike
I don't he wasn't a rat dose or
otherwise his name but basically that
these prisons even are all are turning
into all CI so and all like rats and the
garden he he goes just want is he gets
transferred to prison and the guys in
the guards like hey look
eighty percent my guys are rats if you
[ __ ] start trying start [ __ ] with
them you know what I ain't gonna have it
and he's like it's just a new reality
yeah
just everyone everyone's a rat
everybody's a rat yeah well I mean
there's no benefit to not being a rat
yeah we've we've created a society like
that is I think Cornel West was talking
about it on Rogan where it's like your
honor and character I mean could
anything could anything like I mean you
know we've created an image society with
the image of what people you know you
put forward an image it may or may not
be true right and but that's my thing
that's why I'm kind of I'm glad to get
out of the culture of comedy how long
have we done well of seven okay we're
wrapping it up but the the I'm glad
something about LA I like there's a
culture there that I gravitate to more
people seem to be individuals even
though there's a lot of support yeah
people support each other there there
seems to be it's lonelier there right
it's different than you feel it goes
through you'll still each other out if
you have to well I don't know about that
she that's City you would never have to
there's that there's that romanticized
idea of like oh if you were cutthroat
you could it's not even that point it's
really not even that well what it is is
it's the final leg of the trip and
you'll walk it alone you'll walk the
final plank alone out there yeah and if
it's ends in act like a lot of these
[ __ ] in New York everything's
together and if they walk at a club with
nine other peope you know so is it most
people who started in New York or
Chicago or something yeah some people
started there I mean right definitely
mostly like the opposite I think there's
a lot of transplants we I don't know
okay but it seems to be and I wasn't
shooting on the Midwest you know it's
they listen every comedy club older
comedy club has the same aesthetic yeah
and it just feels you know a little past
its prime and the P
all that are a you know it's like no
longer like when people start bitching
about all these YouTube guy
it's like dude some of them are more
interesting and entertaining I mean look
I don't know what to tell you
well what was that thing the [ __ ] force
10 or whatever name tag team 10 I mean
look I even watched their stuff but I
watch guys who like do historical you
know medieval battle arena yeah well
that's what they do in riot team 10 they
do historical battle reenactments it's
the same thing are they just Civil War
reenactments in West Hollywood if the
one [ __ ] is my point
thanks for [ __ ] hurtin my [ __ ]
point I'm doing a podcast with him soon
Logan Paul by the way I'm excited really
yeah but I don't want to say how and
when okay the point is just be the bar
the dead body he finds listen I would I
would and this is the problem these
people in there you know need to be that
dead body yeah playing your [ __ ]
position it's a great point play your
position
some of these [ __ ] running out here
their lot you know like some guy said to
me in a green room recently goes it's
not about 2 and TV anymore it's about
doing the right TV and I'm like what
sure
can you stop living in the world of
these cliche like think lik like sir
we're living in the ruins what do you
not get it's over bad baby is a
millionaire the president is that baby
the girl who said oh she's a star yeah a
Donald Trump is the president Jersey
Shore is back for another go and it's
one of the highest-rated show are you
really sitting here looking to try to
make sense out of the climate what's the
right TV cam oh I mean at this point the
right TV is running around with an ar-15
because that's the only way you're gonna
get press you think I should weigh I
mean you would be interesting and I
think you should visit you think yeah
you think I would thrive out there well
of course if I if I transform myself if
I didn't true here's me
would like about yeah here's what you
would like about it I think there's no
like this this community like there's a
community of the Comedy Store right okay
uh and and and there's a community in
the but the City of LA so vast so large
it's very hard you you you you really
have to be okay not being able to just
meet up with people immediately you have
to make plans with people you know you
know I think that you might like that
there's no [ __ ] community hmm it's
just kind of it is what it is yeah and
there are people out everybody's trying
to do something out there yeah but it
just doesn't lend itself something like
the social I mean people people people
like me but never liked it and they're
like what is a soul assist LA that gives
New York a little bits of soul right
even that community valid or not there's
a soulful quality to what they're trying
to recreate their family yeah there's
not created you know but it's they're
trying to approximate something they
read about or saw on a documentary right
la is really not trying to do that
they're not trying to do that you know
it's just you know pedal to the metal
unless they put french fries in the
burritos right I mean they do that in
San Diego but you can get a California
burrito in LA - oh yeah when I moved
somebody texted me welcome to hell
it was like it's the leis oh yeah it's
the desert not it's the last leg of the
journey and it's a litter you know what
I mean and I it's time to go it's time
to you know time to make the last leg of
the journey and it's like you know
whatever happens happens and uh you know
I don't what were you miss what were the
few things you'll actually miss and I
know don't say your family my last
episode was called cancel your family oh
yeah of course
mostly I'm assuming restaurants probably
rendazzo walked around I
I will miss restaurants I'll miss places
like rendazzo but I walked around this
area Astoria yesterday and the amount of
diversity and the amount of diverse
people in different stages of pain
walking around you know there that is
raw yeah and you're connected to that
and you're connected to the feeling that
you and these people share to an extent
this community or this experience and
and there's something really interesting
about that and of all the places that
I've lived too but I mean I've lived in
Long Island and a bunch of different
places in the city this part of Queens
has more of the old New York right then
really any part of Manhattan and most
parts of Brooklyn unless you really go
out to like Brighton Beach or whatever
yeah and I will miss that I mean I
bought a belt for $12 and it was just a
nice belt wear a nice leather belt right
up the block and some you know some guys
selling shoes and belts and the shoes
are in a bin and then somebody's got to
be all over his body and give it to you
know it was just a belt like that
I'll miss LA to get to that store that's
a two blocks from my house here in LA to
get to that store two 30-minute Oberer
or and the belts 90 baht like there's
something about so let me ask you cos
like you know look we're talking before
but like st. Maarten over we saw how it
used to be like I always remember these
are movies and stuff Hollywood like
sunset bull lady had like that same kind
of grimy vibe and some is that gone to
in LA or that's so bare I mean I don't
know I think those parts la seem like
Disney World
okay I mean I don't know to an extent I
mean there's no more hustlers and like
Panama and scammers la history is never
as vibrant as it was in New York right I
mean even though New York is very
forward-thinking place New York's
history is so rich so textured la
history's movie history which fades that
just fades right but I would think you
would think like the street urchins and
the Predators and the hustlers you got a
lot of people coming in all the time
they'd be part of this Hollywood machine
so they're [ __ ] good marks you know
keep the machine going I mean the
hustlers and the street urchins and the
truly dishonest contemptible morally
bankrupt people are all sitting in
offices with suits if you're just
stabbing people there's a limit to the
damage you can do where can people find
you you can find me my podcast is called
Kampf I also have a new podcast with
Lucy Steiner our love is disgusting I
both available anywhere on iTunes or
whatever the [ __ ] anywhere you get
your cash yes follow me on Twitter
Instagram a trake umph yeah that's great
very good folks I will be if you care I
will be at American comedy company in
San Diego August 1st through the 3rd
August 4th I'm going down to Charlotte
comedy zone then I'm gonna be at Zanies
in Nashville the stardome in Hoover
Alabama and stand-up live in Huntsville
Alabama I'm it's a good run August 5th
through the a 4th through the 8th 4
through the 9th down there and then I'll
be good nights North Carolina I believe
August 22nd through the 24th
late August come see me with dates in
September coming up - I'll be the stress
factory in New Brunswick I'll be going
back to the comedy can I go to the
comedy connection Providence Rhode
Island first time there I'll be at going
thanks everybody came out to hilarities
great club in Cleveland Ohio that was
really fun that one doesn't it's not as
depressing it's no the Opera Theatre
it's beautiful but Tim Jay Dylan di llo
and on Instagram and Twitter the podcast
is you know gonna we'll be back every
week now we will be on the porch me
Davin and Ben this is our final episode
from New York it's gonna be the final
episode of Tim Dylan's going to hell
the name is gonna change the Tim Dylan
show what we're prompted that well I've
been the hell yeah okay you know we went
we did it so Edie revenue yeah
well no I mean I don't think ad revenue
cares I mean that is the benefit of all
of this yeah Trumpy president what do
you say I offended you um no it's just I
it's time for new sure it's time for new
um it's you kidding this bunch of number
yeah the the Tim Dylan show and it's
gonna be the same show same RSS feed
same everything but I thought this was a
fitting one to do I was like Who am I
gonna get in and I'm like we should have
rayon and a lot of people should check
you out because you are one of those
characters that are being driven out of
New York sadly yeah I mean I feel like
I'm constantly being you know kind of
poked with sharp stick yeah it's not
friendly place for someone like me but
you know so I lash out at people so you
know yeah I'll be fine I'll come see you
in LA
how about [ __ ] come out or come see
me I'll be pushing a food cart maybe
raise the bagel guy
if the bagel guy had enough awareness to
know that yelling doesn't even help you
know me and Ray or those people we're
just past the point we just sit down and
eat the bagel because we know laughs let
me ask Alan nothing good is coming for
this bagel guy his life will be worse in
six months because people are gonna get
sick of him real quick he's gonna get a
few free drinks he's gonna get some a
few you know he'll go gone Jim and Sam
right but in six months it's not I mean
fast forward he's you know he's gonna
move he's got he's a [ __ ] the
bandleader on chemo maracas I mean I
don't know I think Long Island tragedy
seems to always no one has any real
sympathy for Long Island no and I used
to wonder why and man has that question
been answered I pitched a bunch of shows
that have centered Long Island and they
did not get off the [ __ ] ground
yeah and I've always wondered why and I
gotta be honest and we've talked about
this will kind of end the show by saying
this and I've said it before I'll say it
again of all the collections of white
trash on the planet okay there is no
collection of them that has less charm
or less redeeming qualities than Long
Island they're not folksy Hill people
they're not like duck hunter uh well
what do you call them uh duck dynasty
like you know and they're millionaires I
miss it but they're not those kind of
people either that are like living off
the fat of the land trackers no what are
they I mean how would you even describe
them because that's they're people who
know the best place to get a grandma
slice like that's what they do you know
which [ __ ] uh which blockbuster has
the [ __ ] the better copy of
Armageddon I don't know like I think
there was a consumer I think of all the
things that we've done on this show that
we had for two and a half years one of
them that people connected with the most
other than that you know the conspiracy
stuff and all that which will have will
have archives you can hear some of that
but what it what I think we really did
was I can still get messages where it's
like you guys have just hit long island
in the most accurate way you've just
nailed it I've just really nailed well
because most of the people who judge it
aren't a part of the real underbelly we
were yes we like I mean that Pizza Hut
lunch buffet subprime mortgages we were
eating that pizza we were eating that
Pete's leave I mean we weren't just
going we were saying it was gross we
were shoving it down a fat going at a
pace that kept up with all the other
slobs there yeah we like as a the Pete
we had a certain perspective that
usually you know it we don't want when
you hear some [ __ ] guys eating sushi
I can got a nice pocket squares yeah
he's talking [ __ ] about some slob yeah
yeah you know the the [ __ ] count
tri-county no no one wants that you need
to be where the inside track good we
already speak we are deep down we're two
people sitting in a bar whispering in
your ear pointing to everyone else at
the bar going these people are pigs
that's really what it is we're
whispering in your ear going you see
these people they're [ __ ] pigs Tim de
la comédie calm goodbye